wir kommen zum Fragenlotto das sind lose
und hinter jedem los verbirgt sich eine
Frage die roten sind unverschämte Fragen
mit böswilligen Unterstellungen die
Grünen sind harmlose Fragen die
eigentlich die jeder beantworten kann
also bitte ihr dürft ziehen jeder darf
Antworten wie vermute dass es umgekehrt
ist deswegen nehme ich rot ja schon
schon reingefallen ich hatte ja vorher
schon darum gebeten ein rotes zu nehmen
deshalb ne auch ein rotes ich geb mir da
auch keine blöe gut okay so jetzt könen
wir re um machen du
startest ist ja keine Frage das ist ein
fuakt ihr seht scheiße aus könnt genauso
wenig tanzen wie Lena und habt das Lied
noch nicht mal selbst geschrieben ach da
steht kommt noch eine Frage glaubt ihr
dass ihr so Erfolg haben
werdet also ich würde das was wir jetzt
gerade erleben dürfen als Erfolg
bezeichnen davon abgesehen sehen wir gar
nicht scheiße
aus na sagen wir mal so ihr habt euer
Video so gestaltet dass ihr jetzt nicht
als elegant
Popstars rüberkmt sondern ihr seht schon
ein wenig also ich sag mal ein Frau
gespielt von einem Mann mit einem Bart
das geht schon in die Richtung auch wir
wollen auch scheiße aussehen soll ich
mal von vorne oder irgendwo an od ne
nein du brauch nicht anzuhalten okay du
kannst jetzt noch mal auf meine
Nachfrage
erwidern was war denn deine Nachfrage
meine Nachfrage war dass ich gesagt habe
na ja wenn man sich eine Perücke anzieht
und eine Frau spielt und Bart hat dann
legt man sie ein bisschen drauf an
Scheiße auszusehen ach so ja das war
natürlich aus Derin not herausgeboren äh
wir haben ja dieses Kleid gekauen und
ich habe gesagt irgendwie jemand der
lange Haare hat da wussten wir noch
nicht dass wir die Perücke kriegen und
dann dachte ich der Vollbad passt auch
ganz gut dazu und auf den Erfolg haben
wir es ja nicht angelegt jetzt haben wir
sozusagen Erfolg ja trotz allem und
jetzt glauben wir auch dran gut okay
super so man kann ich so oben und unten
abdrehen genau also hier die ach die ist
nicht eingeschnitten die ist nicht
eingeschnitten
ne da muss man auffalten ich kann mir
aber eine andere natürlich rausnehmen
egal du kannst oder ich mach dir auf und
du nimmst schon mal eine andere raus das
ist die Special Frage wahrscheinlich
muss muss alle abarbeiten ne man muss S
auch nicht alle abarbeiten aber die
meisten guck mal
hier die Frage bist du ein Landei nein
ich bin ein
Landgraf aber wohnt wo kommt ihr alle
aus Münster oder seid ihr nur wegen des
Studiums
dahin komm bis auf den Nico aus der aus
Bamberg und der Umgebung kommt sind wir
alles gebürtige Münsteraner und sind
teilweise noch da teilweise nicht mehr
aber Münster ist ja schon verschlafenes
Nest ich meine da gibt ja mehr Fahrräder
als Autos und es gibt elich gar keine
Autostraßen ja also ich sag mal nicht
verschlen ist Berlin mit großen breiten
Straßen und dicken Autos und gut na ja
stimmt ich kann auch auf dem Fahrrad
schlafen spricht wieder für das
verschlafen okay ich nehme alles zurück
und behaupt das GEG also Münster ist
eine pulsierende Großstadt nein nein
Münster ist keine pulsierende Großstadt
aber wir mögen alle Münster das Münster
ist sehr schön und wie findet ihr euch
jetzt so recht wenn man so nach Köln
hier müsst und nach wir haben ja damit i
nicht so geschockt seid dass extra hier
auf die grüne Wiese verlegt ja das
gefällt uns auch ganz gut aber ich
glaube wir kommen auch in Großstätten
zurecht gut das ist beruhigend ja da
müsst er jetzt öfter sein und du hast
auch eine rote gezogen
habt ihr kein schlechtes Gewissen Lena
ihren Hit geklaut zu haben sind ja immer
sehr offen damit umgegangen und sind ja
auch alle große Lena Fans das haben wir
immer gesagt und ich glaube sie hatte so
viel Erfolg mit dem Eurovision Song
Contest dass sie das auch glaube ich
ganz entspannt sieht dass wir jetzt ein
bisschen Spaß zu WM machen hat die das
den WIS ob die das mitbekommen hat hab
irgende Rückmeldung bekommen schon von
ihr ja nicht von ihr direkt vielleicht
aber Manager oder ir jemand gesagt hat
ja ach die hat übrigens hat's gesehen
und war es toll oder also wir haben
nicht mehr von ihr gehört bzw gelesen
als ihren Twitter Einrag der ja relativ
zügig kam wo sie geschrieben hat wie
geil glaube ich und ja dann hat
Christian noch mal mit unserem Freund
Stefan telefoniert genau und der stefan
war am Telefon auch sehr nett er fand
das lustig wir haben ein bisschen
rumgequatscht der war gerade im Urlaub
ja aber ich glaube die Lena war da nicht
mit deshalb haben wir die noch nicht
persönlich gesprochen aber Stefan Rab
hat super gefallen Stefan Rab hat's
gefallen der ich hoffe den treffen wir
dann auch irgendwann noch mal auf der
Couch das denke ich aber mal sicher so
wer zieht g also ich möchte auf jeden
Fall noch eine Grüne haben ja
okay eine eine softrunde jetzt genau
jetzt kommt die softunde haben so viel
Kritik abbekommen ja du h jetzt oder ich
kann auch ja oder warum hat man bis
heute noch nichts von euren kreativen
Ideen mitbekommen ja das wissen wir auch
nicht so richtig wir haben ja auch schon
ein paar Videos
veröffentlicht man denke an 2010 und den
celebrity
Song tja ich denke dass dass wir dass
man jetzt von uns mitkriegt ist
natürlich zum Großteil einfach Glück und
WM und Lena und wir freuen uns wenn man
natürlich in Zukunft mehr von uns
mitkriegt gut sehr
schön das Mikrofon
übernehmen so
was da steht so rum was macht euch so
sexy als Dame von Welt sollte man seine
Geheimnisse nicht einfach so verraten
okay wie habt ihr es geschafft in
Rekordzeit Text Performance Videodreh
und Plattenvertrag
hinzukommen
hinzubekommen ja das ist natürlich eine
Sache über die jetzt auch schon mehrfach
berichtet wurde es war einfach sehr viel
handwerkliche Qualität auch am Werke das
war glaube ich die Hauptsache und manche
Sachen wie die große Unterstützung im
Internet und dann auch die schnellen
Verhandlungen die übers Wochenende bei
den Rechteinhabern stattgefunden haben
lagen natürlich nicht ganz in unserer
Hand sind aber auf jeden Fall eine
ziemlich einzigartige Geschichte
professionell wie habt ihr so schnell
auch professionell hinbekommen brachen
wir ja ein kleines Studio dazu und so
weiter und so fort ja wir machen das
teilweise schon seit Jahren und haben
uns über die Zeit auch ein paar ganz
gute Mikrofone gekauft und auch
Techniken erlernt wie man solche
Aufnahmen machen kann gut dann
kann man also von euch noch eine Menge
erwarten das schließ ich aus dem allen
jetzt na ja ich glaube keiner von uns
hat vor jetzt nach diesem Lied mit der
Musik Schluss zu machen und äh komplett
aufzuhören allerdings ist es natürlich
so dass erstmal das Studium
vorgeht aber ich bin mir relativ sicher
dass man von uns noch was hören wird
super da sind wir sehr gespannt drauf
vielen Dank ja sind wir selber super
sehr
schön